oh mais c'est incroyable non c'est pas
ça
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être non mais
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être bon
simple croyable incroyable ah bonjour
mes chers amis vous contemplez vous
aussi le spectacle affligeant de ce
pauvre casimir à il me semble encore
plus fou que d'habitude
casimir oye qu'est ce que c'est que
t'arrive-t-il mon propre casimir tu vas
tu viens on dirait que tu devenais fou
moi sûrement pas alors pourquoi battu
ainsi dans tous les sens
chez j ai perdu quelque chose mais je ne
me souviens plus quoi je crois surtout
que tu as perdu le nord
quoi qu'est ce que c'est jeudi le nord
tu as perdu le nord du comprend - enfin
je te laisse j'ai une réception mondaine
où l'on m'attend on voir que ça veut
dire au revoir monsieur du snob le nord
si c'est ça que j'ai perdu il faut
absolument que je le retrouve à voile à
françois il va m'aider
françois salut casino j'arrive grand
soir oui qu'est ce qui t'arrive
il faut que tu m'aides j'ai perdu le
nord tu as perdu le nord ouais le nord
mais qui te dit ça monsieur du cinoche
tu sais casimir quand on dit à quelqu'un
qu'il a perdu le nord bien ça signifie
que ans mais je me fiche pas mal de ce
que ça signifie je veux retrouver le
nord et ne plus jamais le père aurait
coûte t'énerve pas je vais expliquer
comment tu pourras toujours retrouver le
nord les enfants venez avec moi voir je
vais retrouver le nord enfin
heureusement voilà ils sont pauvres
casimir qui a perdu le nord
est ce que vous savez vous comment on
peut toujours retrouver le nom comme
rémy avec les étoiles très bien ah bon
vous avez d'autres d'autres façons avec
une boussole oui et si on a pas de
boussole comme le dirait bien que les
étoiles mais deux jours comment fait on
le jour y'a pas des toiles n'y a pas de
points avec le soleil très bien et
comment il s'est par personne rémy moi
non plus tu sais avec londres c'est ça
comment du feu c'est ça quand le soleil
est au plus haut
tu peux prendre oui tu peux prendre toi
mais si tu prends un petit bâton
tu te plantes droit dans le sol et faye
nombre et le nord eh bien c'est la
direction de londres c'est très bien
humide et alors la nuit c'est compliqué
que ça avec les étoiles mais avec quelle
étoile surtout avec l'étoile du berger
l'étoile polaire
vous savez comment la trouver dans le
ciel des enfants on va demander à julie
julie oui tu nous a préparé la carte des
étoiles bien un tir parfait alors à
losail olala serait facile avec une
carte quand même parce que moi j'ai rien
contre ça c'est pour mes baguettes avec
la carte rouge espère garder les enfants
voilà une partie des étoiles qu'on
trouve dans le ciel toute petite partie
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
comment s'appelle cet ensemble des
toiles hissé quasiment chez pas rien la
grande ourse c'est la grande ourse
c'est facile à reconnaître elle
ressemble un peu à une casserole arbre
ou un chariot pas tellement à nous alors
à partir de la grande ourse
comment fait on pour trouver l'étoile
polaire amis
l'étoile polaire c'est celle qui est la
plus brillante
oui mais tu sais il y en a tellement
tellement dans le ciel il soutient plus
grans c'est celle que la plus grosse oui
oui c'est une bonne réponse mais à part
à partir de la grande ourse comme en
photo par lsa du chariot ce côté là ce
qu'on fait ça rémy qu'est ce que tu fais
ici parce il multiplie par 5 c'est ça ah
bon tu fais cinq fois sa distance une ou
deux par trois à quatre sa série du
trouve l'étoile polaire
oui mais dans les deux cas de jour comme
de nuit pour trouver le nord il peut y
avoir un gros inconvénient pour
retrouver l'étoile tonnerre quelles
équipes de jour comme de nuit les nuages
nuage c'est ça quand il ya des nuages
parce que rien des nuages évidemment on
ne va pas l'ombre du petit bateau et
puis ça cache aussi les étoiles mais
alors chaque fois qu'il y aura des
nuages je ne retrouverai pas le nord
les bâtisses et quasi bien ce que je
vais faire gfr cadeau des mains sales
c'est vrai ouais pour la ion merci pour
qu'elle est belle ça ça marche même avec
les nuages ah ouais comme ça tu perdras
merci c'est gentil ça alors je suis
vraiment très content je perdrai jamais
le nord je vais aller le dire à monsieur
du cinéma ben merci julie au revoir
envois révélés
ouah ouah ouah
ils sont bien débrouillés les ophones
didot fait julie tu n'as pas revu
casimir depuis qu'il est parti voir
monsieur de snob
non j'espère qu'il n'aura pas suivi les
nuits de la boussac jusqu'au soir julie
cet épouvantable mais qu'a t'il encore
vous m'avez reconnu et que s'est il
passé casimir tu n'as pas de nouveau
perdu le nord
non mais vous ne remarquez rien non
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on remarque
casimir que s'est il passé encore je
suis allé voir monsieur du snob pour lui
dire que je ne perdrai plus jamais le
nord est
cette fois il m'a dit que j'avais perdu
la tête
[Musique]